so today we're gonna continue our
discussion of equity and efficiency we
started last time talking about the
equity efficiency trade-off well first
we talked about why we think
redistribution might be necessary in the
striking facts on inequality and poverty
in the u.s. then we talked about the
trade-off the equity efficiency
trade-off and the fact that when you try
to deal with a problem like
redistribution
through taxation or transfers you're
gonna have a leaky bucket that there's
going to be inefficiencies associated
with both taxing individuals to raise
the money and transfer into individuals
to spend the money are both gonna cause
deadweight loss so what I wanted you
today is take that abstract framework
from last time put it in some real terms
by talking first about how taxation
works in the US and the kind of issues
we face in taxing people and then
turning to redistribution redistribution
programs and concluding with a very
positive story of sort of what I call a
patch to the leaky bucket and how we can
redistribute in a very efficient way so
let's start by talking about taxation in
the u.s.
and
when I talk about taxation I want to
talk about two topics primarily the
first topic is who bares taxes
who bears taxes now
this is a topic that we call in public
finance the field I specialize in the
topic of tax incidence
now you might think this is sort of a
silly question I mean if you pay tax you
bear the tax why is this an interesting
question and the answer is it's an
interesting question because it's not
true that the person that bears the tax
pays the tax that in fact when you
impose taxes they have complicated
effects on multiple parties because of
the operation in the market okay so as a
result the party that actually sends to
check to the government may not actually
bear all that tax and so that's sort of
the interesting insight we'll start with
today so to think about that let's go to
figure 22 one and let's think about a
tax of the market for gasoline okay
you've got demanded supply you've got an
initial hundred billion gallons of gas
being sold a price of one fifty those
were the days back when gas is 150 okay
now imagine the government comes in and
says we're gonna levy a 50 cent tax per
gallon on the suppliers of gasoline so
the gas stations or the gas companies or
whatever for every gallon they sell they
will send us 50 cents you literally cut
a check that are 50 cents for every
gallon you sell what does that do and
you might stop there and say okay well
then the incidence that tax is that tax
is borne by producers that's great I
don't have to worry about it I'm buying
gas it's those guys selling got stuff to
bear it but you'd be wrong and the
reason you'd be wrong is shown in the
right-hand side diagram which is to
think through the market effect of such
intervention what does the debenture do
well it has no effect of the demand for
gas okay the fundamental main curve your
underlying utility of it of the marginal
gallon of gas hasn't changed but it has
changed the supply curve because
essentially we've introduced a new
marginal cost the marginal cost of gas
has gone up by 50 cents a gallon every
gallon of gas you produce and sell now
bears an extra 50 cent cost so that's
the shift upward of the supply curve
whereas the flat curve is the marginal
cost curve so if I increase the marginal
cost cost of every gallon by 50 cents
that's literally just a parallel shift
upwards in the supply curve supply curve
shifts from s1 to s2
that's new supply curve well at that new
supply curve
you cannot continue to charge the old
price if you get in charge the old price
of a dollar 50 people would still want
to buy a hundred billion gallons of gas
but companies would only want to sell
eighty billion gallons why because the
marginal cost has gone up and we have an
upward sloping supply curve so at a
higher marginal cost they're gonna want
to sell fewer gallons
okay so you have a disequilibrium
what happens is that the gas company
adjusts by sliding up the supply curve
to the new equilibrium point D where
they sell ninety billion gallons at a
new price of $1 80 okay this is all just
standard supply-demand stuff we've seen
that before what's interesting here is
to note that what this means is that
part of the tax is borne by consumers
okay part of the tax borne by consumers
what I mean by that what I mean it's
consumers used to pay a dollar fifty a
gallon and now they pay a dollar eighty
a gallon so the tax has increased what
they pay by 30 cents a gallon now
they're not sending that check to the
government but it's the same thing it's
the same effect the point is this tax
has increased the amount that consumers
pay for gas by 30 cents a gallon so the
incidence on consumers
is 30 cents
the incidents on producers is a little
more complicated they now get a dollar
eighty per gallon right that's great but
for every gallon they sell they have to
send a $0.50 check to the government so
their net price per gallons a dollar 30
so we can see that by taking the new
price at point D and subtracting off the
50 cent tax they have to pay okay which
which now which says that instead of a
dollar eighty they get dollar thirty we
call that the tax wedge the tax wedge is
the difference between the tax including
the price and the tax after paying the
price so it's just a wedge between what
what people get before they pay the tax
and what they get after paying the tax
that's the tax wedge we have a 50 cent
tax wedge here okay and so what is the
burden of the tax on producers well they
used to get a dollar 50 gallon
navigate a dollar 80 but pay 50 cents
the government so the burden on the
producers is 20 cents
okay so even though the producers are
setting the check to the government the
gas stations the gas come instead and
check the government they actually pay
less than half the tax
now nominally they paid the $0.50 but we
don't care about that we just care about
where they end up after the market is
adjusted after the market is adjusted
they are 20 cents per gallon worse off
than they were before and consumers are
30 cents per gallon worse off than they
were before
this is the fundamental insight of tax
incidence that you can't just look at
the paper version of who pays the tax
you have to consider who really bears
the consequences of the tax and that's
why it gets interesting because the
party that bears the consequences is not
necessarily
the party that actually sends the check
to the government
okay that's the fundamental inside of
tax incidence questions about how that
all works
okay so bottom line is all you do is you
say look think about how the tax affects
the market in this case there's an
upward shift in supply curve shift the
supply curve up find the new equilibrium
that gives you the price that gives you
the new equilibrium price and then the
burden on the party not paying the taxes
never seen the new price in the old
price the burden on the party paying the
tax is the new price minus the tax that
you know minus the tax they have to pay
okay
now what's interesting about this is
that within this framework so the first
bowl claim I'm gonna make is actually
doesn't matter who cents to check to the
government the first of all claim it
they wrote the first bowl clay I'm gonna
make is that the amount said I'm check
the government is not the amount you
actually bear off the tax the amount you
bear the tax comes out of this analysis
here's the second Bowl claim I'm gonna
make it doesn't matter who sends the
check to the government if you impose
the same 50 cent tax on consumers of gas
in the same market you get the same
outcome
how's that possible let's look at figure
22 -
now we have a different tax
this tax is now every time you buy a
gallon of gas you pay 50 cents imagine
the outcry imagines the government had a
tax which made gas companies pay 50
cents every gallon they sold they said
you know what we're just going to switch
that and make people pay the 50 cents
could you imagine the headlines the
outcry government screwing a little guy
to favor the oil companies okay but in
fact those headlines would all be wrong
because in fact it doesn't matter to see
why let's look at the diagram 22 - now
imagine we have 50 cent tax on consumers
now the supply curve doesn't shift
because marginal cost hasn't changed but
the demand curve shifts down because for
every gallon you buy you have to send 50
cents the government well the demand
curve represents your willingness to pay
you are now willing to pay 50 cents less
per gallon if you're willing to pay
before at point a the hundred billion
gallons sold they're willing to pay
exactly dollar 50 well if they don't pay
a dollar 50 and acts 10 50 Cent's the
government will not only willing to pay
a dollar for that gas so what that means
is consumers now with the shift in
demand curve if the price stayed at a
dollar 50 they would only want 80
billion gallons at Point C
they would only want 80 billion gallons
for the price of one 50 why because the
price to them isn't 150 anymore okay
they now would they pay the 150 plus
they pay the 20 cents they'd have to pay
another 50 cent check to the government
so they only want so they're so to them
they don't want any billion gallons so
if they knew to a move to new
equilibrium once again we know about
these adjustments we talked about that
you're gonna slide down the domain down
the supply curve and you're going to end
up at a new point D
D is the new equilibrium with a new
demand curve reflecting the much lower
willingness to pay intersects the supply
curve that point interestingly is that
90 million 90 billion gallons flipped
the page back to 20 to 1 that's the same
quantity we had before so we get the
same effect on the amount of gas sold
what's the difference is the market
price in 20 to 1 the market price rose
to 180 now the market price Falls to 130
okay but the burdens are the same think
about the burden on the consumer
the consumer used to pay a dollar 50
now they pay a dollar 30 save save 20
cents but they have to send a 50 cent
check to the government
the burden on the consumer is 30 cents
they save 20 cents on the price and set
a 50-cent check to the government
what's a burden on producers well the
producers used to get a dollar 50 now
they get a dollar 30 so what's the
burden on producers 20 cents same as
before the
point is for any given total tax wedge
for any given total amount of tax who
bears it does not depend on who sends
the cheque into the government that's
irrelevant the side of the markets are
relevant all that matters is the
underlying demand and supply curves and
the size of the tax wedge
as long as you have an underlying set of
supply and demand curves in a given size
tax wedge you don't care who actually
pays because the market will adjust to
offset that
okay and so tax incidence this is an
incredible insight of tax incidence
which is that something I'd imagine most
of you walk in this room today and I
quickly said to you does it matter if
the gas come to pay 50 cents you face 50
cents you'd say yeah it matters okay but
it turns out it doesn't
turns out a dozen as long as long given
a given tax would you give us a supply
and demand curves it doesn't matter who
actually pays okay and that's the
fundamental incident another fundamental
insight of tax incidence and that's why
when you read articles in the paper
about you know this taxes bag is on
people as taxes good gastón corporations
that's not the way to think about it the
way to think about it is what's the
total tax wedge and what does the market
look like
yeah
excellent point all of this of course is
within our standard 1401 framework once
you depart from that for by the way it's
also true even if there's monopoly and
stuff that's still true so this does not
depend on perfectly competitive markets
this is also true in non perfectly
competitive markets so myopic oligopoly
will still feature these two rules
however once you depart from perfectly
rational consumers
then things can change so for examples a
lot of interesting research on what's
called tax salience
and as I said since I won't have time
for a lecture on behavioral economics
this semester I'm gonna throw some a
real economic Nuggets at you but if you
find this interesting take 14:13 it's
really exciting and here's the kind of
insight which is what if people pay
attention to taxes when it's in the
price but not what's wrong up at the
register so they ran a cool experiment
at supermarkets in California they
randomly in some cases increase the
price on the Shelf by the sales tax in
other cases they kept the price fixed
and the sales tax is running up at the
counter like we normally do and they
found that affected demand that affected
how much people wanted the good even
though the net price was the same
because it was more salient when it was
built into the price than what it's like
at the end when you just bring it up you
don't pay attention to it yeah
well that's exactly what I said that's
exactly what this there's two questions
one is how to stack the demand curve
that's what I was saying that basically
the demand curve I mean it's not quite
your question a question about sort of a
like a moral like do I feel differently
if one's being taxed another you or you
talking about the salience point
yes I I think I think we don't I I think
we don't know for sure sort of the moral
aspect but the salient aspect we knew
for do know for sure which is how the
taxes presented affects people's demand
even though it shouldn't now is another
question but you're gonna ask which is
how does the fact that you can see a tax
affect people how people feel about
taxes so here's a super cool study my
colleague Amy Finkelstein did you guys
know that easy tack easy passed the
thing on the highway were you okay so
when states moved when I was a kid you
just have wait on line and pay cash to
get through the tolls okay now you just
drive through with your EZ Pass so
what's happened is it made the tax less
salient right it used to be you'd feel
pain every time you go through the toll
now it's just some billing at the end of
the month what she found is when states
switch to EZ Pass they rapidly raise
their taxes on roads they raise their
tolls because people didn't mind as much
so they could raise them more so there's
sort of an interesting politics aspect
to this to this as well so this matters
having said that I'm gonna ignore it but
this stuff does matter and that's why
behavioral economics is fascinating okay
now there's a third point I want to make
about taxes so I talked about who bears
taxes I talked about the side of the
market
side of the market is irrelevant
and
then the third point I want to make
about taxes is it's all about the
elasticity
which is who bears attacks for a given
tax wedge who bears the taxes all
determined by the elasticity the supply
and demand curve okay and in particular
inelastic parties get stuck with taxes
while elastic parties avoid taxes so
inelastic agent inelastic firms
inelastic consumers they get stuck with
taxes while elastic elastically supply
firms or lass demanded goods they avoid
taxes so to see that let's look at
figure 22 three
okay let's go back to our tax on the
suppliers of gasoline once again I hope
you know by now it wouldn't matter if we
did the demanders of gasoline but it's a
little easier to see with suppliers of
gas let's go back to our tax suppliers
of gasoline so we have a supply curve
that's been shifted up by 50 cents let's
consider two markets one with perfectly
inelastic demand one with perfectly
elastic demand in the market with
perfectly inelastic demand we used to
sell a hundred billion gallons at a
price of 150 now we Latvia 50 cent tax
on suppliers where do we end up we end
up still selling a hundred billion
gallons of gas you have to because in
elastic well if you're going to still
sell a hundred pounds of gallons of gas
then the suppliers can't bear any of the
tax they have to be able to fully pass
the tax on to price that is they have to
be able to charge two dollars think of
the logic suppliers have to be on their
supply curve the supply covers just
shifted up by 50 cents therefore if
you're gonna sell the same quantity the
price must go up by 50 cents so in that
case who bears the tax
who bears this tax on gas
don't raise their hand tell me yeah did
you repair all of it right consumers
bear all the tax suppliers bear done
supplier you said you're studying 50
cent check to the government but you're
getting 50 cent higher price so you
don't care okay sir to sent Joe here
into gas I don't know how you do
whatever okay so so you um so you so you
don't care okay now let's flip the case
let's imagine demand for demand for gas
it's perfectly elastic
okay now the supply curve is shifted up
by 50 cents okay supply curve is shifted
up by 50 cents now what happens is
consumers say look I don't care how you
feel mr. supplier I'm not paying more in
the dollar 50 for gas I've perfectly
elastic demand
supplier has no choice then but to eat
the whole tax because if they try to
pass any of it on to the consumer the
consumer revolt so the new equilibrium
is that the where the price stays the
same of a dollar 50 and the quantity
Falls in this case the producer bears
the whole tax the consumer pays no more
they did before this gas company gets
the same price later before but has set
a 50-cent check to the government so the
entire burden is borne by the producer
what is going on
why do it why with inelastic demand
what's the intuition here fry with
inelastic demand could sumers end up
getting stuck with the tax and with
elastic demand consumers avoided yeah
right exactly I like to think of this a
very good explanation I think it's in
terms of almost like negotiating power
it's not the right way to think about I
think is useful intuition that when
you've got inelastic demand you've got
to go no negotiating power you just want
insulin you're gonna pay anything for
insulin so the supplier knows that so
he's gonna make you pay the whole tax it
doesn't matter if you send the cheque
got any sense to check the government
he's gonna pass the whole cost to you
but if you think about fast food if you
think about a tax on hamburgers if you
charge your penny more for hamburgers
I'm gonna buy a hot dog or a slice of
pizza then the supplier knows there's
fruit they have no leverage you have all
the leverage you've all the negotiating
power so they can't raise the price on
you so the bottom line is inelastic
factors get stuck with taxes and elastic
factors avoid taxes okay and that's sort
of the other lesson we get here as we
think about about about taxation
okay so at the end of the day all that
matters if you think about any tax being
imposed in the US it's never as simple
as just the gas tax off in a complicated
giant set of taxes we think how simple a
single tax all you know is the
elasticity is applying demand and the
size of the tax and you're done you can
figure who bears the tax okay and then
Gretchen alleged office for example does
these exercises all the time and has
estimates of how given tax changes will
affect the income distribution as a
result
okay now um and actually there's a
pretty cool study of this let me ask the
question we have hospital taxes we at
was Hospital we've Hotel taxes got too
much health care on the brain we've got
we've got hotel taxes in many major
cities
okay there's some instance of hotel tax
you can imagine diagram have got
supply-demand how does the incidence of
the hotel tax change when Airbnb comes
in
yeah
yeah
exactly what you see and how would you
test that how would you test that yeah
what you find is when air B&B comes in
hotel prices have to hotel taxes are
passed less on to price
hotel owners are more barring the taxes
compared to consumers because consumers
are more elastic so that's sort of an
example of how this can matter okay so
now let me say one other one other thing
about taxes the last thing I want to say
about taxes is
what to tax
and this is a fundamental debate that
goes back to the 17th century which is
essentially should we tax people based
on what they produce that is their
income or
should we tax people based on what they
consume their consumption
ok the philosopher Thomas Hobbes in like
17 whatever talked about why should we
tax people based on the fruits of their
labor let's tax them based on what they
take out a society that is what they
consume and this is a debate economists
have had for centuries should we tax
consumption or income this debate which
shows the real world because in Europe
they rely much more on consumption taxes
than we do yeah
I'm going to show you why it matters so
Europe they rely much more consumption
taxes than we do so in the u.s. most our
taxes come from income tax in the Europe
a lot of their tax rate comes from
what's called the value-added tax and if
you've traveled in Europe we'll know
about the value-added tax which is a
form of consumption taxation so this
debate that plays that international in
the US we have sales taxes but they're
quite small as a share of revenues
compared to European nations now why do
we care well we care because the
following equation why your income can
either be spent on stuff or saved
you're giving to be spent on stuff we're
saved
okay and we and as I talked about a few
lectures ago savings is a major engine
of growth in the economy
more savings means a broader pool of
capital
means a broader pool of capital which
means a lower interest rate which means
firms can invest more so we like
promoting savings in the long run in the
short run of the recession may feel
differently but in the long run we like
having more savings so over the long run
we like having more savings if you tax
income you tax both my consumption and
my savings if you tax my consumption
then you don't tax my savings that is
you relatively favor savings over
consumption you promote people to safe
rather than consuming
okay so that's why many economists I
think probably if you did a poll of
economists and said should we taxing
America's assumption the majority would
say consumption and the reason they
would give is because we need to we need
more savings in society and we'd to
promote that yeah
that would be identical equivalent if
you give a 100 percent tax credit for
all of your savings that be identical
now in the u.s. we have some partial
credits like that but far from 100
percent okay so the question is what's
the counter-argument well the
counter-argument is all about fairness
which is that it turns out that the rich
save and nobody else does
basically almost all the savings Society
is done by the top probably ten percent
of individuals in society and
the bottom 50 percent of integer society
have basically no savings
so essentially what this means is for
most Americans for the typical American
this debate is irrelevant because they
have no savings
the attacks throwing them eat extra
consumption it's the same thing for rich
Americans it'll be a much better deal
with tax consumption because they have
savings that then wouldn't be taxed
so the problem with the consumption tax
base is being mean a massive
redistribution
from the poor to the rich because the
rich folks do the savings
now there would be a simple answer -
there would be an answer to this we
could answer this because ultimately
right the rich folks die doesn't matter
how rich they are they die eventually
okay and if at that point we taxed all
their savings we could then equalize
things so in other words if we took all
the money that was left let's say we had
this consumption tax but we counted as
consumption the money you left behind
when you died
then it would solve the problem because
the rich would during their life they
pay less tax but they pay it all at the
end
but the process but that so that's why
such we have such a critical debate in
this country over the estate tax or the
so-called death tax okay this notion of
sort of whether you should be taxed on
their estates becomes very important for
thinking about this if we had an estate
tax was literally at the same rate as
all the taxes then we could move to tax
a consumption it would be the same in
fact we would essentially have a
consumption tax at that point okay but
in fact we have an estate tax that are
paid by the top point is paid only by
the top point oh four percent of people
who die each year and it's paid on only
a fraction of their assets so we don't
have that so that's why the fairness
sort of debate comes in okay so just
want to point out just another these are
all just sort of topics I'm hitting to
sort of whet your appetite these are
sort of interesting things we need to
think about we think about how to set up
our tax systems is basically things like
do we tax income or consumption okay
questions about that
okay that's taxes now I want to turn to
so that's one side of the equation which
is taxes we know they cause
inefficiencies we know that cause
deadweight losses
okay we know there's some and we know
that there's some question about who
bears them but the bottom line tasks of
putting some leek in the bucket and
that's a problem the other side of a
leak in the bucket is transfers
which is as we saw in the diagram last
time if you tax if you essentially
conditioned by getting money on my
working a work if you say to me hey John
if you you're currently making $5,000 a
year I'm gonna give you $10,000 no
matter what you do but any money you
earn will come off that $10,000 I'll say
great I'll just quit
okay so problem with transfers is they
aren't they act like taxes okay if you
take the transfers and phase them out
take them away from people they have a
similar effect we in fact we call
transfers an implicit tax so out of our
transfer system from last time which is
the amount you got was the max of 0 was
the max of 0 or 10,000 minus your income
this is essentially a hundred percent
tax rate on everybody's incomes below
ten thousand dollars right because for
every dollar you earn we take it away
because you get ten thousand no matter
what so this is a tax basically
but in fact this tax is unavoidable if
we want to target money to poor people
if we just gave everyone ten thousand
dollars it wouldn't be a tax okay
we just gave one ten thousand dollars
now it would impact how hard people work
why
well it impacts so how are people work
yeah
no no I'm going to like labor supply
theory what's the name of the effect for
why that would affect Cardiff again when
$10,000 the income effect so what effect
how are people work but it wouldn't
really distort people's labors we
leaving them distortions arising the
substitution effect people making
different decisions because their tax
rates the reason we get a problem the
reason we get deadweight loss is because
I'm take I'm not going to give you
$10,000 that I'm taking away as you get
richer
okay that's the problem so then the
question is what can we do about this
what can we do about the fact that we're
essentially imposing implicit taxes on
poor people by giving the money so the
couple answers the first is
categorical transfers
that is instead of giving the money to
everybody just give it to deserving
populations
okay so for example one of them the
largest single cash transfer program
pure cash transfer program in the US is
-
that's literally giving cash is what's
called the SSI program the Supplemental
Security income program it's about 80
billion dollars a year and what this
does is give cash grants to low-income
families of disabled children
so it's not just that you're low income
but that you have a disabled child in
your house
okay likewise we have something called
the TANF program
which is what is traditionally called
you know I've used the term welfare in
this course - meanwhile being Church in
the America when you say welfare was
sort of a sneer on your face you're
referring to Tanis okay TANF is cash
grants to low-income single family
single parent households essentially if
you're low income and you're single mom
typically you get a grant from the
government
now the question is always asked is why
do we impose these conditions why do we
make people disabled why do we make them
be single moms why not just give them
the money why not have this why have
these other conditions and the answer is
because that basically we think this is
a way of reducing
the distortion that arises from
transfers think of it this way imagine
all of us were born with on our forehead
an unremovable tattoo that said
hardworking and lazy no let's not do
that different thing let's do low low
slow skill and high skill okay and that
so I know your underlying ability then I
would simply say look if you're a high
skill you don't get any money I don't
care if you're poor if you're poor just
means you're lazy because I know your
high skill if you're low skill I'm gonna
give you money and that would not
distort behavior at all because people
couldn't change what's on their head so
they would just continue to work as hard
as they always worked
this is the idea of trying to find
signals like that you're trying to find
ways of identifying the people who need
the help and by doing so who need the
help but need the help in a way that's
not changing by their behavior
okay we think that a kid being disabled
they didn't choose to be disabled or mom
being single mom she didn't choose to be
single mom that starts to get a little
bitter interesting okay so essentially
if you have categorical welfare is to
basically say can we find things about
people that they didn't choose on which
we can base giving them money
okay so blindness is a good example etc
okay now the question that then raises
what can people choose these things
well you might say well of course a kid
can't choose to be disabled but mom
people can choose to be single moms okay
in fact the evidence is the opposite let
me explain what I mean if you give
people money tied to being a single mom
it doesn't cause them to be a single mom
the evidence is very clear on that so
there's been hundreds of studies showing
that paying women money conditionally
making a single mom doesn't cause them
get divorced or have kids out of wedlock
that's been clear but if you give family
money based on kids being disabled more
disabled kids show up
why because disability is a tough thing
to assess most disabilities are
musculoskeletal or mental and those are
hard things you can tell if a kid's
missing a limb but it's hard to evaluate
truly musculoskeletal or mental
disabilities and interestingly despite
your intuition when it might have been a
few minutes ago the place where in
subsets we see the most people changing
their behavior to qualify at least
change of behavior meaning not becoming
disabled but claiming they're disabled
is here and not in single motherhood so
categorical transfers help but not as
much as you might think because the
categories are hard to measure
okay and that's why another tool we've
used to try to get at this is
in-kind transfers
in kind transfers
okay part of the problem yeah
it's a great question that's that's a
tricky thing they have to deal with
which is kind of you know which is sort
of how do you deal with Co residing
people and that's something they have a
complicated set of rules
[Applause]
question and so basically here's the
trade-off okay give me a better way to
teach it here's the trade-off the
trade-off is the more you target let's
say I said I'm gonna replace our entire
welfare system America would just
transfers to the blind unless soon
people don't blind themselves to get
money okay you laugh but there is a city
in Florida uh where um where they found
that over a certain period of time the
vast majority of us claimed for lost
limbs came from one city in Florida and
it turned out that people are actually
cutting off their limbs to qualify for
government money they actually called it
nub city so you laugh this stuff does
happen but by and large we assume it
doesn't okay so let's say I wanted to
place the entire US welfare system with
with one just people who are blind on
the one hand that would be great because
you wouldn't cause any distortion people
wouldn't worry working less hard because
you can't change whether you're blind on
the other hand you leave all these
people out in the cold who need help so
that's the trade-off which is the
broader you spread it the more you move
towards sort of a universal system the
more potential distortion you costumes
of people change in their work behavior
but the broader set of people you can
help and that's why there's a big move
now for what's called universal basic
income ubi is a big movement now around
the world to say look forget these
things SSI TANF they're all Bessy to
measure their arm stigmatizing people
could change them anyway let's just give
people money and that's sort of a that
sort of one motivation for that now but
the other way to get at this that people
come at is look the problem all here is
a simple one which is everyone loves
money rich or poor we all love money but
what if what we gave people was not
money but things that poor people need
and rich people don't like for example
mediocre public housing not a mansion
but an apartment a rich person isn't
going to pretend they're poor to get a
crappy apartment or mediocre apartment
or a poor person to be homeless
otherwise we'll happily take it
what about medical care rich people have
private health insurance they don't need
government have medical care poor people
need government medical care what about
food stamps ok rich people can't afford
food or
poor people can so the idea is basically
by giving in-kind transfers like medical
care or housing or food we get people to
what we call self
reveal
that they're poor here the problem is
people might pretend they're poor to get
the money they might quit even if
they're not even if they can afford or
that I quit here we say well look you're
not gonna quit your job to get a
mediocre you guys with your you know
make it a hundred grand a year at MIT
I'm gonna quit your jobs to get some
mediocre public sector apartment ok but
if I said I'll give you a hundred grand
with your work or not you might quit
your job as they be given a mediocre
apartment you won't so the idea by
giving people in kind benefits to get
them to self reveal whether they're
actually whether they're actually poor
or not now that's not the main reason
why giving hunger transfers this is the
economists reason the main reason is
because because politicians are what we
call paternalistic
and this comes all the way back you guys
remember when we discussed food stamps
and we just budget constraints and I
said well we never agree that people's
would sense we want to give them money
and they said but what if the Y axis
labeled cocaine then we would want to
give them food stamps because don't want
to spend their money on cocaine well
that's how politicians feel about poor
people they feel that poor people if you
give the money will just waste it and
that's why
the vast majority of transfers here in
America are in-kind if you add up all
the money we give people in cash versus
the money we give in kind particularly
medical care the in-kind dollars vastly
outweigh the cash dollars and that's
because politicians are paternalistic
they're afraid now that mean the
economics reason is because there's all
this models self-revelation that's not
why can't white politicians do it they
do it because they're worried people
will waste the money if you give them
cash and I think we showed with the food
stamps and the evidence that's not
really the right way to think about it
okay
questions about that
okay now this is all kind of negative
and nebulous so let me sort of conclude
with a great example which an example of
a public policy which actually doesn't
stop the leak in the bucket actually
puts a patch in the bucket and that
policy is called the Earned Income Tax
Credit
the EITC
okay this is what's known as a
conditional transfer
what that means is it's a program where
you get money but the money you get is a
function of how much you make up to a
point so it's actually the other way the
other thing the HT even call this a wage
subsidy
so here's how the ITC works let's go to
figure 22 four I'll show how the HEC
works here's how he works
for every dollar on the x-axis is how
much earned income you have on the
y-axis the check you're gonna get from
the government what this says is on
every dollar you earn until you earn
thirteen eighty seventy these numbers
have been out dates a little more now
but roughly gives the idea until you 13
eight seventy that is saying this ruffle
the poverty line right it's a little bit
more in the poverty line for every
dollar you earn the government gives you
40 cents more so if you weren't if
you're someone who starts with you and
you're earning a dollar you take home a
dollar 40 it's a negative tax it's a
subsidy so every dollar you take home a
dollar 40 until you reach earnings of
thirteen eight seventy at
point you've achieved a check of five
thousand five hundred and forty eight
dollars that's 40 percent of thirteen
eight seventy at that point the
government says it's the biggest check
we're sending you and we're gonna keep
that flag until you're in eighteen one
ten and then we're gonna start to take
it away
we start to take it away
so that by the time and what we're gonna
do is we're going to take that 55:48
check down by 21 cents for every dollar
we earn it's gonna flip from a negative
tax to a positive tax at a twenty one
percent rate so set of a negative tax at
a forty percent rate we switched a
positive tax at a twenty one percent
rate so that by the time you've earned
forty four four fifty four
okay you have you zero at your ITC so
for most of you the ITC will be
irrelevant okay for most your families
the ITC is irrelevant so it's a targeted
transfer program conditional transfer
was conditional because basically its
condition I'm working but it's targeted
in the sense that it phases out such
that middle-class and upper-class people
don't get it it's targeted to
lower-income people through this phase
out
the problem is
this makes the EITC effect complicated
so let's consider
let's consider the three segments of
this graph let's start with the first
segment let's say you were earning zero
and I said for every dollar you earn I
will give you 40 cents more
okay what effect does that have on your
labor supply
starting from zero
yeah
substitution effect to make you work
more because essentially raised the
price of leisure by 40% what about the
income effect
there is no effect so the point is for
someone at 0 this unambiguously creased
their labor supply so if you take guys
who aren't working this definitely will
I mean it might be a zero effect but
it's non negative effect on labor supply
likewise with low income working low
hours the income effect will be small I
mean income effects proportional how
much you are actually earning so for
these people that on the left-hand
segment upward sloping it should cause
them to work more because the
substitution effect to be big in the
income effect will be small
so if you mark the people on sort of
this left-hand segment you should mark
their work more now what are people in
the flat segment someone with someone
else raise their hand and tell me what's
just going to do the labor supply people
on the flat segment
it work more or less yeah
well there's no the wage hasn't changed
but something has changed
you know the well that's not quite
that's an extreme model more generally
it's because of income effects more
generally the point is I've taken
someone and made them v $5,000 richer so
compared to a world without the ITC
that's I shows better with at the ITC I
will now work less there's no
substitution effect only an income
effect so now I work less so the first
part think I'm a substitution effects
the second part is just an income effect
now what about the third segment well
they're assuming Ledger's normal do I
work more or less
they work more or less assuming assuming
ledgers assuming Ledger's normal yeah
that's because
substitution effect and income effect
because your income is falling as
because as you because the point is as
you work more your income is falling so
here both the substitution and income
effect combined to make you want to work
less so if you look at this graph this
doesn't look very promising on the Left
we've got a bunch of guys working more
in the middle we got guys working less
and the other side we got many guys
working way less because you have a
substitution and income effect
okay so the question then is what effect
does the EITC have and the answer is it
turns out as an enormous li+ effect on
labor supply then it gets a lot of guys
who were working zero to stop working
zero but it doesn't seem to lower the
hours among those who working more than
zero hours
now why is that
unclear it could be because there's
different elasticity's along the income
distribution probably cuz probably it's
because of tax salience whoever I wrote
that whatever the hell I wrote that tax
aliens which is the people understand
gee if I go to work I get a big check
then understand by the way the marginal
hour I work is being taxed at 21 cents
more so probably it's tax salient I
don't know but the bottom line is the
studies show convincingly that
introduced in the ITC massively
increased labor supply and
distribute to the poorest people in
society this is a reverse leaky bucket
literally managed to take money give it
to poor people and make the pie bigger
so this is an enormous victory for
thinking about how we can forgetting
around this problem of how we can
transfer to people now it doesn't solve
all the problems because I'm gonna
comment up here it doesn't know people
who don't work so there's still this
isn't the only solution we need because
some people literally can't work so you
can't benefit a program like this but
for workers this is an enormous success
FFEL program that is really one of the
great sort of government success stories
in terms of both transferring to poor
people and increasing the size of the
pie alright I'm gonna stop there and so
we'll come back on we'll come on I'll
see you guys on Wednesday